Sometimes bad things,
horrible things happen to good people and
I don't, I don't know why,
but
life isn't fair that that's,
that's the reality and disease like
cancer and ms and horrible diseases and
accidents and these things.
A good person in the wrong place
in the wrong time can
end up just a victim of,
of, of feet and,
and of reality.
And it can be horrible
and heart wrenching,
but
when those bad things happen,
okay
to people around you,
what are you going to do?
How are you going to lead?
Are you going to get angry or
do you going to get frustrated?
Are you going to lash out at people who,
who are you going to lash out at anyways?
Are you going to start going
down the spiral of negativity?
Are you going to let this horrible
situation dictate the way you feel and the
way you handle it?
Are you gonna fall over and
fall down and fall apart
or or are you going to lead?
Are you going to face
this issue with courage,
with resolution?
I say lead, lead,
step up to the challenge.
Be the one that other people look to
absorb that impact.
Absorb that negativity.
Draw fire, draw fire. That's,
that's when a member of a platoon for
for tactical reasons steps into the open
to draw enemy fire.
Maybe to give another part of
his team the chance to move or,
or distract the enemy. But
that's what I say, draw fire,
bring that pain to me. I can handle it
when, when, maybe others cannot.
And when, when bad things are happening,
I am going to try and
be the one good thing.
The thing standing tall
that can be relied upon
because I know that that
attitude will spread.
It will bolster those around me and,
and we will fight.
And in fighting we will win.
And if not the battle, and if not the war,
we will win because our spirit,
it will never surrender
in that
that is the ultimate victory to hold your
head high and even even in the face of
inescapable defeat
to stand and to fight,
that is to win.